[Musik]
viel spaß die hin und weg wünscht drs
können und wasser vertragen
der unterschied wird aber auch dass er
demokrat ist und die schweiz das ist
schon extrem attraktiv
ford kommt eigentlich nicht hier hilft
ersten blick sehr fasziniert
nein
[Musik]
islam
libby frank nicht noch ein baby von
grenzenlose liebe nimmt die usa die hand
und schon immer hin und weg
was den schweizer liebesgeschichte welt
[Musik]
in dem interessante hus direkt am strand
wohnt sie zweier nico schlicht grund
sehr bekannt vor nicole berlin hat vor
über 2 im schweizer fernsehen
verschiedene sendungen moderiert denn
als sie ihre koffer packt und bezogen
küste vor
das trikot
eingesprungen bin ich wenn die zahlen
[Musik]
als chefin vom eigenen hotel und mutter
der siebenjährigen lila ist zieht aber
sei nichts gut
[Musik]
nur lachen
ok
com
schon mal vor
[Musik]
gbagbo okay
seit elf jahren ist er rasch er
polizeiinspektor der marokkanischen
stadt ist sexy
bei taxi sondern einfach das ist immer
oder die bis eine frau mit den sticks im
rucksack mit 416
[Musik]
als schweizerin gold berlin und
marokkaner rasch interesse verschlage
auf sansibar die insel mit dem
klingenden namen wozu tansania gehört
geesthacht anissimow kurz begrüßt er
stets nie so richtig wie wählen paradis
sich dort landet bin ja normalerweise
wäre das die küche
[Gelächter]
das heißt ich mir selber gern droht und
die an recht und wir haben schon dank
des trans und meint damit aber auch
stelle
der freak city high wenn man ist kunst
das muss einfach nach 12 jahren und
frauen und natur und dir gefällt
nein aber es ist ihr bild mir gefällt es
nicht keine ahnung was es bedeuten soll
es interessiert mich aber auch nicht
[Musik]
sid elf jahres in nicole unterschied
könnte erst im zweiten anlauf klappt der
erste versuch ihre marokkanische könig
platzt
das heißt wenn er schon sicherheitsmann
von der polizei darf nur noch sehr wenig
im land ist also irgendwelche rote armee
auschwitz gesehen und gehört und dann
gehst du quasi forum alter von
zivilstandsamt
er ist ein bisschen von sich eine krone
hat probiert durchsetzbar
durch das papier von könig und schrieb
der könig ist in frankreich und probiert
einfach am flughafen
wir haben es uns unser closed beta das
heißt wer illegale ausreise obwohl die
beamten nicht im lande oder als
ergänzung sein
na gut mir probiert zumal 43 steht noch
ein geburtstagsfest in 40 staaten
und das ist ja oder nein der york sein
wir hatten ja schon unterschrieben
da kannst du ja oder nein sagen es macht
keinen unterschied mehr
ich mache nur spaß
[Musik]
angefangen hat es eigentlich boni
facebook seite entdeckt die reise sitte
und das matterhorn abbildet und da habe
ich das nur spannende frage ist
eigentlich auf schwedisch und da habe
ich das gleich ich hoffe ich erzähle
dasselbe ich glaube es war
ich bin nicht sicher das gipfelfoto das
gipfelfoto dachte ich mir da war dann
ein kommentar von ihr so ging es hin und
her
so begann es
[Musik]
florence und niklas in kurorte führe
zurzeit aber neue pcs verschiedene
gründe
doch auch später noch dazu
[Musik]
buchen abschieden routinen aber es
bleibt aber so ist das nun mal
wir werden täglich miteinander sprechen
nachrichten schreiben und wieder tschüss
sagen aber wir haben dafür auch sehr
viele glückliche augenblicke
jedes mal wenn wir uns wieder hallo
sagen können dass gleich das ständige
tschüss sagen wieder ein bisschen aus
tamgho
die beam nicht so viel futter tue ich
gar nicht das ist das dicke fell
[Musik]
dass ich sie lange bevor der flugverkehr
in ganz europa wegen corona virus
treimer brauchen ist dass es führt
florence und niklas bald viel
schwieriger wird zum 16
wenn sie da nicht ganz
[Musik]
flavio
solange mit jemandem zusammen zu sein
ist nicht schlecht wir arbeiten zusammen
wir schlafen zusammen
[Musik]
wir frühstücken zusammen
das ist wie wenn wir statt zwölf jahre
24 jahre zusammen wären
man kann die zeit eigentlich verdoppeln
[Musik]
sid zwölf jahre sind nicole unterschieds
eimer und romantik über lohn sind
zwischen deiner wozu ihnen flitterwochen
mit dem tabu
montagny auf die einzelbett was
natürlich nur zehn macht
nun ist und ob es okay
auf sansibar ist bis auf die zwei
gezielten im frühling und im herbst
eigentlich immer saison und rumpelt
nicole unter rashid bis zu 40 heimische
forscht rund ums jahr einen job kommen
tag vergeht ohne dass neue gäste im
hotel ballardini jacket hallo ich bin
die nicole gut also dann begrüßen wir
euch mit dem welt kommen drink
[Applaus]
so haben uns sehr wohlgefühlt
[Musik]
nicole ist direktorin vom host ein
bedauern teil für ihrem ersparten ist
projekt investiert mit folge wo sie
unter rashid notfonds erhält die lokale
behörde einnahmen noch nicht so recht
wüst werde mit hugo dass nicole als
freies geld bringt als investorin ich
sie sofort will chromik sie aber ihren
wahrheit bis zum heutigen tag kraft die
aufenthaltsbewilligung über hoch war er
umgekehrter invest oxy geht's für sie
die frau sofort der bewegung geht auf
ihr pc ist das nicht immer einfach sie
wie sieht es jetzt aus mit einer
aufenthaltsbewilligung
die situation ist dass ich nun schon
seit zwei jahren warten
aber nicole hat die bewegung bereits ja
weil sie investoren ist und mit
eigentümerin des hotels
deshalb ging es bei ihr schneller und
wie ist der aktuelle stand hat sich
jetzt etwas geändert die
arbeitsbewilligung habe ich es schaut so
aus als bekäme ich nun die
aufenthaltsbewilligung sicher ich will
keine zahlen nennen
die chancen stehen bei 55 definitiv weg
sie aus dem ferienparks und martina
strutz hat sich australiens was als
ferienaktion hettich längstens ernst
wurde kurz nach der hochzeit cale zudem
martina schweiz und hat sich bestens als
zwillingsschwester melanie und ihren
freund sandro handy misst herz
geschlossen
sie laufen durch so horn wäre perfekt
wenn martina und melanie anna manager
bald müsste für zwillings
[Musik]
zum zweiten mal in nur zwei jahre alte
cale und martina abwege wehrmacht
kompromiss und was sind sie bereits im
zug blau für elia
meine freunde und familie sind natürlich
auch für mich das wichtigste aber mein
glück aufzugeben mit meinen hobbys um
einen lifestyle okay das war zwar nur
für zwei jahre aber also wenn du gesagt
hat ist kaum in die schweiz und bleibt
für immer
ich weiß nicht was ich gesagt hätte
minute wurde auf preis und martina die
eigene wohnung trend und sind birnen
älteres buchs und man merkt schnell auch
wenn sich die ganze familie für das
glück von einer weide freut
einfach wird der abschied nehmen vor
[Musik]
bevor sich alles mal eben wieder neuen
zusage für sie ganz einfach um sich aber
genau gleich schnell
vor allem in dem moment wo sie den
abschied und brot kaufen und so das wird
sicher nicht einfach
[Gelächter]
das komitee und der kleine stürmer und
hängt
dass ich im januar 22 sie den hier denkt
dass sie die nächsten monat alles ganz
anders und als planen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wer ist neu die größte wahl brachte
[Musik]
der 6
trotzdem nicole ihre liebe zum wasser
sind so ausflug aus familie sind beide
in beschlag
[Musik]
wenn ich weg bin sagte sie
müller oder was
ja aber ich bin mir bewusst dass der
preis des familienlebens polizei sie und
sie hat der nachtdienst also
jetzt auch mit der caritas bei meiner
arbeit als wirklich zu viel manchmal bis
zu 16 stunden
auch hier arbeite ich viel von morgens
früh bis abends wenn ich abschließen das
zwingt nicht manchmal darüber
nachzudenken was ich hier überhaupt
machen es genau das gleiche
ich habe gekündigt alle meine freunde
und familie in marokko zurück gelassen
für nicole ist das hier der traum am
stand zu leben und ein hotel zu führen
für dich nicht nein meint es nicht
nein nein nein das kann ich so nicht
akzeptieren
achtung ich verstehe schweizerdeutsch
und die spiele
da gibt es offenbar noch lebend
operation spiel ruhe
klar ist ob familie ich mitte liga
komplett und den strand einen zaun
inklusive aber tropischen aquarium
wartet zum abtauchen und allfälligem ist
unvergessen
[Musik]
die zwei jahre ist niklas aus schweden
die große lehre von florence solang sie
aber noch im kanton solothurn wohnt gilt
die regel merckx am kite mindestens so
verhöhnt
insgesamt 74 beinahe hat sie früher oder
später wenn florence dann ganz zum
niklas zu blöd waren drago und mit dem
schweden war nie wirklich gedanken oder
wenn es ist schwer aber es ist auch gut
so sagt worden so war ich nach einer
sehr schnell wieder im hinterkopf sie
mit heinz wie viel über den afghanistan
gegenteil
eigentlich war das der grund dass man da
nur schwer heute mitteilte im bau ist
eigentlich
die tochter neuer steht jetzt im doppel
und sie ist nur hier und sie ist also
sie hat psychisches problem war sehr
schwierig ist im auto und bazire dort
aber ähnelt mit dem zügle florence und
ihre tochter hat für irland den
grundstücken schwere tier bezugsbereit
ist doch die natur entspricht
und wenn ich sage ja die wir gern mit
bezahl sehen dass apotheken hierfür
akademie ist so sagen sorry aber was und
sie können auch zur familie und karriere
vor augen dafür luft vor für mich
[Musik]
der nikolaus wie bringen wohnt in
jönköping im süden von schweden
[Musik]
aber er hat zwei erwachsene kinder
der linus und den ja und nein stimmen
und das ist ein test und ja ich hatte
noch nie einen hund
doch dann traf ich diese frau und die
hat 2 300 von denen und weil sie
irgendwann hierher zieht und mindestens
268 hunde mitbringen wird will ich nun
versuchen mich daran zu gewöhnen
das ist wenig zu testzwecken von ihrem
mitgenommen habe den blinden leo er ist
schon ein ja bei mir
wir haben es gut miteinander solange er
nicht in mein bett kommt ich habe
nämlich eine leichte hunde allergie -
und wenn ja könnt ihr kurz zum hund
schon schaffen
im gegenteil es zeigt höchstens wie
ernst es ihm ist sie ist ganz erspart
die hätte genau zum physik und florence
als traumhaus im waldbau natürlich wenn
sie in einem halben jahr sagen würde ich
komme nun doch nicht wäre das schlimm
ich wäre wie soll ich sagen
finanziell ruiniert
die hinter niklas übrigens nicht groß
mit i bezogen bonner mit der florence
plan für das neues leben geschmiedet auf
oder hochzeiten sie nur indirekt
erfahren
[Musik]
ja
wohin fliegt also wähler weniger extrem
gern schön gespielt und sehr wohl das
ist reine fleiß und das überhaupt wenn
ich gehe das zu weit
und sie war als kind das mag ich gar
nicht das hat mit gegenseitigem respekt
zu tun
es geht nicht um religion sondern darum
dass ich mitbestimmen will was sie ist
aber sie liebt das ist mir egal es geht
um erziehung dies ist ein kind im
augenblick entscheiden wir noch was sie
ist ich mag die regeln nicht
bitte nicht mehr wir brauchen salam ich
gar nicht erst aufzutischen wenn sie da
ist
[Musik]
das hotel am strand vor sansibar ist
nord idee für den xii sehr zum start
etwas für geschätzte doch jeden tag
daran ja es ist schon mein geschmack
mein gott das duo wird christi receiver
mit mode und klappe unterstrichen wissen
wünsche dass ich nicht anerkannt
was macht das mit reduziert also sicher
nicht mehr gebraucht wurden geschädigt
sehen
es ist nicht neu und vielleicht auch so
würden wir sind ja weltkrieg hat in
nordafrika geschaut dass ich wenn ich
mich gestellt haben
denn wirklich an den kreis der störung
sei und was mit den machen
[Musik]
zwei lebensentwürfe unter einen hut
bringen
das vermeintliche paradies eine dreifach
der raschid der ehemalige
polizeiinspektor und marokkanische
sahara hätten moment frucht zum sich mit
den neuen standards freunde
[Musik]
es war nicht dein traum sondern der von
nicole warum hast du dich trotzdem
entschieden hier ein neues leben
anzufangen
erstens wollte ich sowieso aus dem
polizeidienst aussteigen bin ich jemand
der nicht allzu lange nachdenkt vor
einer entscheidung
und drittens wusste ich dass nicole eine
starke frau ist die mir auch helfen
würde die ersten schritte zu machen
dass nicole chefin und damit eigentlich
auch die vorgesetzte von haschisch hat
sich auch viele bezieher ausgewirkt die
neue rollenverteilung und sind die
abhängigkeit von der nicole ist für die
ehemalige marokkanische polizei
inspektor einfach sie im torhüter neuen
anlauf zum sind status verbesseren
hallo minister eric wie geht's gut ist
mister ali können wir ein wurden abend
mister ali
wie geht es der herr ali es endlich
geschafft was die rasche zwei york mitte
behörde erfolglos probiert bewilligung
ich brauch der druck groß ergeben ob sie
herum haggis länger dauert seither an
und übergibt es am rashid lang ersehnt
die dokument
[Musik]
dann können wir jetzt teuer
vielen dank besuchen sie uns mit ihrer
familie kommen sie zum mittagessen oder
zum abendessen
wieso das jetzt plötzlich alles so gut
klappt
[Applaus]
ja
brennan
[Applaus]
nicole ist die treibende kraft für das
hotelprojekt in sansibar der rashid hat
wohl oder übel da sich nicht ganz
spurlos an eine beide vorgegangen sodass
du einen tragischen ehrung mit steffen
und ihrem team über eigene lager und +12
york city und im grad so die führung
glaub mir repräsentieren wie die meisten
nachzahlt krater spitzley das ist ein
verfluchter wird die talkshow es ist
einfach sind es super gut funktionieren
die familie sagt man machen
romantisch tönt das will ich nicht ob
dafür ehrlich dass die zwei jahre ohne
schmetterlinge im bauch noch eng
verbunden sind das gespürt und ich
zweifle keinen moment dass sie noch
viele spannende projekte traf fort mit
freundin ruine bekanntheit exakt kids
zone zur musik richtig mal okay und ich
bin gestürzt so die hosen gemacht
[Gelächter]
14 jähriger sagte krug zum ersten mal
wieder claudia vor der türe gestanden
ist sido ich zögere mit mein base cup
profi zweimal langhans miami klebt wilde
group wie der miami heat und vertrag hat
und dort sie jetzt claudia immer noch
häufig jetzt aber für ihre eigene
geschäft sie ist das catering bis
musikstücken
[Musik]
wenn man ja ich hab ja schön worden und
tritt nach net und holz bis business ist
sehr gut wie die athleten viele andere
superstar singen oder rapid wo sich der
neue puma-chef leisten
claudia ich ursprünglich nicht weg der
linie die usa wo sie ist zirkus artisten
und tänzer xi und hat sich die
vereinigten staaten karrieren aufbaut
bis am valentinstag ein großer mann
ihres lebens großes thema hund alle los
angeles und den dunklen und das ist ein
folgenschwerer zu erfahren die zwei sind
jetzt seit über zwei jahren kürte und
hat zwei töchter
[Musik]
ich bin
der krug oder die ganzen namen acrobat
javascript prof eine botschaft aus
frankreich hat in seiner karriere über
italien bis in die amerikanische
national basketball league führt die
beste liga der welt jetzt kriegsende vor
sich aktiv karriere krönt normal user
vorträge team war ein abstecher auf
afrika
und
ich bin in frankreich aufgewachsen meine
frau ist aus der schweiz und meine
kinder sind in den usa geboren
wir sind also total gemischt deshalb
interessiert mich afrika ein weiterer
kontinent je mehr man sieht verschiedene
kulturen offen sein gegenüber anderen
das ist das beste ich hätte nie gedacht
dass basketball mir das ermöglicht
ich kann mich wirklich glücklich
schätzen in new york
casting für die mannschaft stand chance
wurde krupp unbedingt die parks
wie schon so manish ist ja kuba allein
tracks weg für seine frau claudia und
seine beiden töchter basketball als lebe
vom jacoba völlig auf den kopf gestellt
als sohn vor senegalesische niveau
anderer parisi einfachsten verhältnissen
wachsen
geldsorgen sind hubkraft thema mehr als
leiter von meine superstar hat nachteile
das bilde ist man es dem weg hab
zeitverschiebung facetime und skype sind
schon gut aber natürlich nicht das
gleiche aber eben wir haben dieses leben
selber gewählt
uns hat niemand gezwungen
wir wussten beide war für uns ein ich
habe nie so gedacht
ich hatte vorher nie eine partnerin aus
einem anderen land
es war nie ein thema es ist einfach
geschehen ich glücklicher synchro
abteilen mentalität verschiedene
mentalität der show band rollt sie haben
viele die erfahrung gebracht und die
heimlichen sind negativ erfahrung
gemacht mit andere mentalitäten bin ich
dann gegenüber sehr offen
[Musik]
florence ist flight attendants sie hat
bis vor kurzem aus der pflege geschaffen
und lebt mit der jüngere tochter jada in
derendingen ältere tochter laura ich
muss sogar und chrono man ab und zu auch
[Musik]
für bleibe die dem große usa massiv
erhöht
[Musik]
ja wir jetzt im ersten mal reagiert ich
war so ein tier häufig nicht rum der
haut der hund kaufen und auch nicht so
schlimm vorgestellt
keine client einzig die beide über
facebook er hatte französische manager
x8 und frau vom leben gefunden
wie hat er reagiert nur auf seite durch
habe ich ihnen schwebt verliert ja also
es ist ziemlich komisch sei am anfang
war es eine magische 100 meter opel
verstand und schenk mit der sprache
eines problems so der schweizer für mich
und das ist natürlich wichtig dass meine
familie die familie passt und harmoniert
und kreiste dann wohl hier
das weißt du wie der frauen wg oder
hunde wege wie fix nicht dass das
duftspray bezüglich aha also das ist
schon das wurde nicht aus jetzt baut das
ist so konzipiert dass ist jetzt im wald
ganz sagt lagen allein außerdem mit dass
allein zu sein das ist für den rechten
ja ja und ja es kommt auf neuer dürfe
sie hat jetzt not leben jetzt noch nicht
ganz
und als grund die band auch wieder vor
dass jeder schaltfläche einstreichen
oder sich genau in der spd erste
kenntnisse aus der weniger zu akuten
symptomen hat wie so eine panikattacke
für mit problem mit einem schwulen
verständnis natürlich merken so zeigten
die angst geht wo du kannst es die im
heute in irgendeinem schweden statt sie
hofft natürlich habe es ist auch für uns
ein problem hat sogar dazu ehre und das
ist nicht komisch
das muss ich mit dem ratschlag wie ich
das für die mit neuer und du ist ein
sehr einsamer genau wie sie die ängste
und der moment dass du wirklich weißt du
wenn du immer jung wie groß das ist
schwierigste thema natürlich dass es so
eine teenager sagt daniel epp zanni wo
ich die unbeschwert ist die harmonie der
muskel uns gedanken machen sorgen und
nach zeigt wie sie bloggt ist mit deiner
angst also das ist schon was ist drin
das ist und der vorschläge machen wie
das neue in zukunft die hasen mit dunkel
ich sag jetzt mal das nachsehen
also das ist wie beim roomster und man
sich gedanken gemacht und bin in einer
schlacht die mutter wenn jetzt gleich
oder ja also für mich ganz klar das er
lösen muss da sie bevor das ego das eine
öse grundfalsch erneuern muss es stimmen
[Musik]
ja
messi co
damals gerade halt stolz sein und singen
zirkus eigentlich alles was ich bin
sozusagen zum spielfrei werbe oder
spieler golfrange autos erinnert das
ganze aber nicht gekannt habe
[Musik]
spannende show des stars wie claudia
diawara ganz ursprünglich rufen und
amerika braucht es überhaupt nichts
türkei mit catering oder mit hoch
sondern
mit einer ganz großen traum posiert
wieder vorbei mit dem traum vom zirkus
noch ihren anfang in der schweiz hat
claudia mit 18 zirkusschule vom cirque
du soleil in montréal zurück
[Musik]
betrauen weitere karriere außerdem hat
claudia becker effektiv geld dafür hat
sie dort amerika trug eine klärung vor
ihrem leben wir beide ein
kurzentschlossen nägel mit köpfen macht
[Musik]
am morgen die nicht ins team und meine
freunde fragten was machen wir
anschließend und ich sagte ach ich
heirate wo trifft man am samstagmorgen
sportbegeisterte familie oben
trainingsplatz
[Musik]
china
da bricht mir neu
hey hey hey hey ich weiß dass ich die
zwei in los angeles keine klaren trend
aber was ist es eigentlich gnauck sie
wurde zwei metern am anfang so
fasziniert
zuerst fiel mir ihre coolen hosen auf
sie trug männer die wie eine hip hop
musikerin
sie trug ein rudel und diese am 8
wie war deine kleider machen
sie wollte gar kein date mit ihr das
bild für dich
blöd für sie lasst es geschafft sie
umzustimmen
wir haben anfangs miteinander geplaudert
ihre freunde hatten von ihr erzählt
mutter wir haben uns wieder getroffen
dann fingen wir an mehr miteinander zu
sprechen ist erzählten einander von
paris von zürich es half mir dass die
französisch sprach
immer mehr gerät und im herzen so
ergeben
für denver miami atlanta und
zwischendurch immer wieder psyche der
schweiz und frankreich familie diawara
führt diese international bleiben weil
ich meine dass heute eingespielt
ausschuss überhaupt realisiert was davon
stellenwert hat nein du sagst du für den
schweizer markt ist dass wir spielerisch
oder so ein professioneller athlet
das hat mir nix kein hockey und all das
was das überhaupt ist okay war das etwas
das dich angezogen hat dass sie eben
kein fan war ja sie kannte das nicht und
das war gut
sie war nicht eine wie diese leute die
genau wissen was du tust und voller
bewunderung zu dir kommen
nur so kannst du die ware person sehen
ob du jemand wirklich magst so wie er
ist und nicht weil er der ist den die
leute im fernsehen sehen
[Musik]
dennis wie vor vom hat sie nie zu hoffen
ist wirklich und zudem hat sich das war
nicht groß die frage gestellt was man
jetzt hab ich das weg heißt schweiz und
das verstrahle sich das probiere das ist
ganz klar das ist und wie lange
am mittwoch 8 seit mehr als 22
martina und kay plötzlich schnell vor 24
stunden sie ihren flug auf australien
vorbereitet
[Musik]
aktuell und wo muss ehrlich gemeint ist
und durch durch woche vor
und vielleicht einem vertraulichen und
dezember entscheiden höhenflüge
psychologie so vom strahl mit und wie
groß der stx vor ihm flügelflitzer
vorgezeichnet es ist ganz wichtig dass
man denken es ist alles kind das ist
alles verkauft es ist alles braun monat
und service im 1 halbjahr mit der
planung gestartet und ich mir was
ja es war viel gebracht
eigentlich hätte sie um die ba erst
gegen straelen muss wanderer jetzt ist
sie mit liebe zum sich so wichtig vor
freunden und bekannten zu verabschieden
immerhin die ganze familie schmidt zum
flughafen
für den augenblick und der innige
umarmung
[Gelächter]
ich bin schon auch gut
[Musik]
und dann gehts kreis zurück melanie und
martina die unzertrennlichen zwillinge
den chiplead die ganze welt zwischen 10
[Musik]
ja
mit
[Musik]
natürlich war ich sehr nervös als ich
dich damals am flughafen abgeholt habe
wir dachten oh mein gott wir haben nun
das gleiche hotel zimmer für drei tage
was ist wenn es nicht klappt was ist
wenn wir uns miserabel fühlen und am
liebsten sofort wieder nach hause gehen
würden
naja ich hab als letzten wir entschieden
uns dafür es locker zu nehmen und
einfach die tage zu genießen
[Musik]
wir verabredeten auch dass wir wenn wir
uns am flughafen sehen mal gar nichts
sagen würden bis zum mittagessen und
erst beim mittagessen sprachen wir
darüber wie wir uns fühlen genau so
machten wir es dann
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die zwei york kenneth sich die zwar
jetzt im nächsten juni
[Musik]
ja
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
perfekt
max die uci magna wäre hätte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
eigentlich wohnte nikolaus am
wunderbaren ort station shipping in
småland
im sommer ist der sache nicht mehr viel
einfacher sehen ist und das auch am
sandstrand liegt und das wasser das
schönste feeling
[Gelächter]
aber reden wird florence nur die
kombination mit 700 darf die gez am
stadtstrand bald passé sein
niklas bald an die zukunft und die elite
halbe autostunde weg fordern
[Musik]
das paar fragezeichen und viel vorfreude
spürt man wieder florierende micro vans
ihres künftigen die heizung
[Musik]
hier ist der eingang
wir stehen im haus wir sind in der hand
hier kommst du dann rein bringt die
hunde reihen voller dreck und bringt sie
bis hierher
da gibt es eine art badewanne für die
hunde
du steckst sie rein waschen dann kommen
sie ins haus
dafür liebt sie mich weil ich solche
sachen machen und hier ist eine rasche
unsere waschmaschine du bist die bessere
gesellschaft von natur und schwein sie
mit der easy erhöhen
ich habe das auch die frage gestellt wie
ist das wenn wirkt das alles und wenn
jetzt wieder hier steht am tag was ich
sage ist überhaupt nicht das ist es ist
keine einsamkeit es ist es ist eine
freude
[Musik]
er bietet einfach sehr viel aber
glücklich sie und was besten ist für ein
sauberes man selber happy ich
unglücklich und nicht nur das
[Musik]
hin und weg ist sexy es so dass browns
zuvor über zähler
definitiv auf amerika kritisch zur mit
dem jakobus paris tanzleiter
seither sind nur zwei herzen leid liebe
zur ruhe und ariana und alessia
[Musik]
und ehemalige basketball-profi ist
besser im ganz brauchbare home smart
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber vor der klärung
pizza
wie ist das schön hier wir vorher schaut
alles geschwister und ich hatte mir was
sie zum abgleich einfach gestrenge
streng ich probiere ich glaube ja auch
mit ihrem ehemann group aber da nimmt
lukas entscheidend das hat auch claudia
passt schon mit 18 ist sie auch
zirkusartisten sport daraus profit and
performed und selber musik videos
gesucht
[Musik]
der yakuza diawara x7 karrierehöhepunkt
wie der miami heat in der nba gespielt
schon vor senegalesische android pariser
verhältnisse
basketball hat mich eigentlich gerettet
wenn ich nicht sport getrieben hätte
wäre ich vermutlich noch dort meine
mutter hat mir beigebracht zu tun was
man tun möchte meine mutter war eine
kämpferin sie und mein vater standen
immer um fünf uhr in der früh auf um
nach berlin zu fahren und dort läden zu
putzen
mein vater arbeitete als straßenreiniger
es war immer mein traum mit dem sport so
viel geld zu verdienen dass sie nicht
mehr arbeiten müssen und das habe ich
gemacht begrub und claudia sind beide
sehr jung für europa amerika zum große
treue interview kirche oder sexy von
amit genannt verbunden verstand die
videos der städte die ihre karrieren
aufbaut und dann hat ihn keiner kennt
und durch grüßen wenn du mit ihm wächst
seine sie alles machen erwerbsleben sind
immer noch mal was macht das singen der
circus als sexy und spieler zu haben
dass alles immer mit ihren maßen wie mir
ein surfen ist und ich kann das nicht
gewusst was man so viel wirklich was
mache ich was mache ich denn da machen
mit
geige oder was ich dass er dafür sorge
dass die usa an das ist ja immer das
mindeste das repertoire das sie muss das
jetzt für die er wird immer alles
gemacht das sind alles lügen und frage
und ich glaube sich auch damit müsst ihr
auch die beschäftigen dortmund mehr viel
an land schön das heißt man muss jetzt
alles was dir alles sagen und dann hat
er seinen sachsen wo man irgendwie schon
so dass schlicht billiger kaufen und
dann irgendwo frauen und ein baby care
wo man sachen anhänger scherte bringen
bei den damen stellten dabei all die
spielerfrauen events sogar um den
badesee und eigentlich wie es verlierer
das ist nicht aufgehoben heißt das
gemacht wofür infos für die zukunft was
mir ein wähler erreichen für familie und
ehrenamt merk ich muss da sie will
eberhardt so viel freiheit wenn ich mir
da bin ich zufällig gestoßen ich sage
der maschine zwischen herausragenden
partner exotik zum buch passt
[Musik]
mit begleite claudia dalbert sie ist
also privatrecht und ihrer ehrlichkeit
krajnik was mich erwartet
[Musik]
sogar jetzt gehen wir zu einem grund hi
und da ist jetzt gerade am trainieren
und woche drin und lästern für internet
und wahrheit untersucht wärme und ist
dann ja
was macht der professionelle
fußballspieler also dass in rage so
richtig wahrhaben rainer für deinen
spieles hat lädt wieder gut also macht
vor allem für profisportler ja alles nur
profisportler oder haien clients sage
mir wie ein mädel chefs also mehrere
kirchen unter mir schaffen wodurch
angestellt sind für mitglieder und altes
paar kunden mit spezifisch und mit einer
kita in der heimat so viel wenn ich an
[Musik]
denn da die agenda ist also ist das
villenviertel so das ist der hintere
teil von roswell wo sehr viele blätter
darunter große das ist gerade
parlamentsgebäude
das ist das private das rauschhafte
moment bist du doch
[Musik]
dass amerika alles größeres weiß mehr
eigentlich aber das basketballfeld auf
dem vorplatz hätte nicht jedem
[Musik]
der stolz den schlüssel oder die
grundsatztreue hatten kein gutes haar
[Musik]
doch das system hat mit deutschlands
keine frage dass bei der profis sind ja
weiß dass nur das stella ein begehbarer
es war geschlagen
genauso wie immer alles schön aussteller
das sind alle maße wachsen größte gefühl
so einen begehbaren kühlschrank
kleiderschrank für frauen aber das
begehbare vorratsschrank der begehrten
immer alles umzustellen und er hat das
selbst angehören
ich finde dass er war mega cool dann
werden wir alles schön ruhig da damit
mir immer gesehen sollten hand und
irgendeine partner ist unangebracht
aber wenn sie schnitten jetzt
verstärkung der woche und er wird
einfach lästige frauen fussball
weltmeister witali ist okay also ein
bischof was auch wie befürchtet
wir sind hungrig auf immer noch für ihn
dabei muss immer aufpassen und auch
befreundet sie wahre freundschaft ein
star es selbst nicht das natürlich es
kann passieren aber ich besser
professionell partei will sicht ist ein
schwieriger mit dem schaffen mit dem
zahlen und der klasse finde wie es geht
wie macht man das die balance dreifach
claudi gramm zu setzen
vor der us armee zum beispiel über jahre
schon meine spieler oder optional in
moskau mit einer aber regelmäßig wie man
muss immer danke und das ist mir wichtig
dass man eben wieder erschafft und ein
teil von mir ist
was machst du da warst also nicht die
karriere oder die jungs gegen die akp
[Musik]
und während claudia aus es macht kümmert
sich begrub die heimkind aus mandeln
durch weiterbauen
drückt man ja schließlich ein zwei meter
großer baum
[Musik]
wie hat er sich die roma trick kunde
entscheidet so drückt dann hat man
einfach nur so will er hat immer auf sie
sind hat dann kein job sieben führer
neuvertrag und dann einfach mannschaft
war nicht immer gut gemacht ich sage ich
hoffe jetzt ich und du du bist irgendwo
okay damit seid vorvertrag etwas
abzugeben
ok und da in der mainstadt diskussionen
offen
nein findet sich jetzt mehr gleichzeitig
meer gestürzt herzig ist das denkt dass
er das so packe ich ihn immer ganz
einmal ganz andere seiten keine client
oder alles ist immer um ihn jetzt noch
cool wie in irak seit frühjahr hat er
was immer tickets kollege und jetzt an
ihre tickets für irgendwelche games oder
body ist und so und nimmer e-class
probleme mit dem breit wenn aber schon
kräftig geld habe er ist ein ganzes
spiel war der heimat grosse diskussionen
über den knopf zum lachen
also doch auf die dauer der seit drei
wochen
meistens sagen steht uns und die gruppe
ist ein bisschen zimmer hat ganz schöne
woche
und tuna a
[Musik]
da sind das beste das ich spiele golf
spiele unsere golfspieler
nein sicher nicht max oper bis hin zur
hand dann hoch meisten stars sucht will
sind dann meistens im moment ihrer nennt
sich das kino aber dahin haben es als
nakba bezahlt wird so fühlen was ist das
für ein boot
[Musik]
vor 48 stunden sind martina und dort
darüber stürzt in syrien flog weg der
korona krise und der grenzschließung
sind viel früher musste schwyz weg als
ursprünglich geplant kein moment früher
wie sich zeigt
[Musik]
der australischen westküste ist
gewachsen
wie sehr vor zwei jahren zu den martina
aufbruchs zu politisch hat er australien
und nimmer
[Musik]
nein
noch eine stunde dann sind wir ihn uhse
meine mutter wird sich extrem freuen
sie erwarten uns überhaupt nicht ja die
haben keine ahnung
ich zittere ich bin so nervös
die zwei entnehmen zeit dass ich mich
darüber erzählen überrascht werden für
eltern und schwester von kate
[Musik]
[Applaus]
überraschung
[Musik]
hätte ich das gewusst hätte ich
abgewaschen um mich gekämpft
[Musik]
fazit gerade seine uniform an und macht
sich bereits zur arbeit zu gehen
welche überraschung
die letzten 48 stunden waren so
aufregend das ist die beste überraschung
in meinem ganzen leben
[Musik]
ich danke dir ganz festes zu so gut auf
meinen jungen aufgepasst hast
[Musik]
es happy end noch lange und ungleiche
reis und staub vom gemeinsamen lebens
australien
[Musik]
die beiden vor und casey soll die autos
restauriere und das auto ganz australien
reisen
das trotz grüner möglich ist
[Musik]
wir haben kinder und familie müssen
sicherstellen dass alle zufrieden sind
wir haben eine vorstellung wie wir es
machen wollen
aber vielleicht landen wir in einer
sackgasse
und natürlich gab es auch zweifel daran
ob das alles wirklich klappen wird
[Musik]
22 krise sind die regelmäßige psyche
vorläufig nur möglich
die ist natürlich jetzt gar nicht auf
ein herr tipp pro woche und ja immer man
das nicht wenn das ist spitze
das steht natürlich wieder starten und
auch einen relativ schwierig hallo wie
geht's dir studiert jetzt gut und hier
hast du stress
ja wir haben mit krone jobs angefangen
demontieren plexiglas an der rezeption
und kassen war etwas mit dem haus heute
heute war niemand dort wie geht's dir im
quarantäne land immer noch das gleiche
ich lass dich jetzt deinen corona jobs
ja wir haben immer noch drei orte für
uns bist du okay
ja klar
[Musik]
box
fernbeziehung führen als ehepaar per se
schwierig aber wenn das virus noch
grenze dicht macht gutem englisch
verzinst wenn sich florence und niklas
wiederherstellen
sie ist weder französin noch muslime
das war vielleicht ein problem sondern
eigentlich wollte die familie jemanden
für mich auswählen
deine mama hatte schon jemanden im kopf
nicht unbedingt eine mutter halt sie
wollen einen immer beschützen
jetzt rächt den jüngsten beschluss
akzeptierte sie meine entscheidung
und jetzt ist es gut
also sagen wir besser
[Musik]
ja
es ist so mutig und familie diawara
machten ausflug ist grüne
[Gelächter]
bradley amerikanischen ganze familie
erzählt 20 sie sehen der lady may
bringen der besorgung machen das ist
dann immer überzeugend und eher nicht
schwierig
daraus hat sich definitiv kein dresden
präsent
[Musik]
unterschied gibt's viel mit einer weide
herkunft religion und auch körpergröße
gemeinsamkeiten aber genauso nie
geschafft für das was man macht die
beide teams und der glaube an die
gemeinsame zukunft
die zukunft der usa erstmals ich habe
noch nie da und wissen nicht genau wo
waren die schweizerinnen job hat das
cover wie immer größer und mich fragt
die schweizer dämliches gut und du
bekommst den schweizer pass wir arbeiten
kannst du dir vorstellen die usa zu
verlassen um in der schweiz zu leben
warum nicht ich bin ja europäer
vielleicht könnte ich in sachen
basketball etwas neues in die schweiz
bringen
ich könnte den schweizern die
italienische die französische oder auch
die amerikanische spielweise beibringen
ich habe ja überall gespielt das wäre
cool warum nicht das recht hier immer
hin und her belegte marcel internet und
am ende des stückes wünschen auch dafür
zu erkrankten familie
dass man endlich mal fixen ebit blieb
mit 100 m
mein wunsch war es in der nba zu spielen
kinder und eine frau zu haben
nun wünsche ich mir alles was ich
gelernt habe weitergeben zu können
jetzt könnte ich zurückgeben was ich
bekommen habe
hin und weg für bares unterschiedlicher
länder ist die ideale führt
[Musik]
weg gebracht
thanks man
japans ab
[Musik]
zu
die gelben
es wird
zurück
[Musik]
obwohl kritiker sprachen extrem gut
verstanden
nun werde ich relativ klima ersichtlich
ist wie ein floß arbeitslosigkeit zu
mieten an viel als dass man nicht auf
dem standesamt gegangen kirche
[Musik]
region
hin und weg während luther menschen
kennengelernt putzt aus libyen grenzende
internisten überwinden
seine geschichte
[Musik]
berlin
mai
[Musik]
hinunter ich präsentiert wurde von dr
oetker